when it comes to reproduction than men
do as in a baby being born so you and
you're talking about power as in like
power to get the to keep the baby not
have the baby get the baby fostered or
addicted or
um I think that power's been put on
women
um I think that there's like a lot you
know bringing up the womb womb people
letting people in the womb but your your
sperm should be quite you know quite
important in this so the question I
asked was do women have more power than
men like do women have the final say
yeah no no some men have the final say
so it's not your body your choice
anymore I don't I don't I think it's I
think when it comes to a baby it's it
takes two to tango and I think that
there's two people who have made this
baby two people have a decision to make
together as to what's in the best
interest of the the two people and the
possible baby okay so so using that I'll
say okay so it's two to tango okay you
get pregnant I have sex with you you get
pregnant I say
I don't want a baby great me neither no
I'm saying me saying that do I have the
power to stop it yes yes I don't have
the power to stop you from having a
child
because it's your body your choice you
can choose I can't I can't choose to get
rid of that baby for you yeah otherwise
you can do that yeah otherwise every man
would be getting rid of accidental
pregnancy exactly I have a question for
you
um would you be okay with men being able
to sign off their rights as a father
um because we have the right to get an
abortion yes so you'd be okay with like
them being able to sign off financially
I think that both people should be able
to do that if it's consented and
communicated any like people should be
able people should be able to do so even
if women like want to keep the kid you'd
be cool with that yes okay at least what
about you guys what do you think I feel
like you can do that I feel like there
is a way that you can sign off your uh
not necessarily you can but it depends
where you're at but not necessarily it's
not because in some places that is
already a thing because I do agree I
think both people have the option to
decide how involved they're going to be
in a child's upbringing and if someone
doesn't want to be a part of that then
there's it's not a good idea to force
them right and what about child support
you'd be okay with them being able to
sign off and
um
yes I think if two people have had this
baby accidentally there's a good chance
that they're independent anyway so kind
of relying on your own kind of
independent source of income you know to
have a baby and stuff like that
especially if you're the one choosing
the other person isn't then yes I think
that's fair okay what do you think
I can give my own anecdote 11 an
anecdotal evidence with like my my
biological father wanted to have me
aborted and him and my mother were quite
young and they didn't yeah didn't get
along and
my mother made her choice and it was it
was Grand and I've lived to be a happy
adult and I've caught up with my
biological father many times and he's
fine but I don't have a I don't have a
continuous ongoing relationship with him
and it's completely fine like it's not
like like yeah it hasn't affected me I'm
in the slightest like yeah okay what do
you think
um I agree that they should be able to
sign off because yeah because I've got
friends that have been gone pregnant
while a guy they're not with in a
relationship with he doesn't want her to
have the baby she goes ahead I think at
that point when you have that discussion
and he decides
then I think you should
you'll know how that's then gonna go so
then it's your choice if you want to
make that choice and have the baby then
I don't know it's I think it's on you
personally what do you guys think I
would say no absolutely not to to give
them an ex like from a selfish point of
view yeah oh man we get to sign off I'm
out of here but from economical point of
view that's probably the worst thing we
can do is allow men to negate their
responsibility to that child and let
them sign off and have an easy pass out
because I think a lot of I don't want to
generalize but I'm assuming a lot of
women are saying it's fine I can do it
myself but it's not about you it's about
what's best for the kid and the kid
needs his father so do you think do you
think abortion should be illegal then
like if we're gonna make it equal no I
don't know the question but it should be
legal so then why do you think legally
women should get a choice whether or not
they want to be mothers but men
shouldn't have a white man shouldn't
have a choice whether or not they want
to be fathers if I'm raising a son and I
tell them a girl gets pregnant it's 100
your fault I've been with way too many
women I've never got a girl pregnant so
there's no excuse a guy can say no I'm
talking about from a legal perspective
though I'm not an industry
responsibility so then why don't you say
the same thing to a woman like if you
got pregnant it's your responsibility
yes to both right right but you're
saying one should be legal and one
shouldn't why do you like why the double
standard no wait what double standard so
the double standard where a woman has a
choice of whether or not she wants to be
a mother but a guy doesn't have a choice
of whether or not he wants to be a
father so I said I said he wants to sign
all away his rights you're saying so
they have the option yes I do believe
that okay it should exist okay I'm not
like saying I would create a society
where I'm promoting it I don't think
it's healthy I agree I agree I agree
with you I think if you look around how
many dumb people that exist on this
planet I think a lot of these people
that get pregnant should not be having
kids and think the worst thing you can
do for our economy is allow them to
bring another baby in this into this
world when they're already pretty messed
up or on drugs I'm thinking that kid's
going to end up in the foster care my
parents are foster parents so I can just
see the trickle effect for all this
stuff so in that even though I don't
like abortion and stuff like that I just
think it it should absolutely available
I personally think that this whole like
feminism has given women a lot of power
and taken power away from men and then
what happens is a lot of the time women
generally tend to use that power to
their advantage when and where they see
fit so like in these cases like in the
cases of abortion like look my body my
choice my body my choice I get to choose
I get to choose all right cool I'm a dad
I get to choose not to oh you're a
deadbeat dad
it's like
what's that all about like if you can
get to choose not to be a mother why
can't I get to choose not to be a dad I
I don't think you should not be able to
choose to be a dad that's what what
yeah you were gone she agreed but they
they didn't answer or he didn't so
that's why I was asking okay so I think
if you do get a girl pregnant you still
are gonna have to finance it because if
you don't Finance it who's gonna Finance
it right the woman has to take care of
the child and raise a child and she's
gonna be spending all her time raising
that kid and she won't have time to work
and then the government's gonna have to
step in where's that money come from
right so it makes sense that the
government wants you know mandated paid
child support for their baby
well it was her choice to have the baby
though it is the guy's choice to get her
pregnant no it wasn't yeah it was I I've
trust me I've slept with so many women
never got a girl pregnant so
it was it was his choice like just like
you said right
um You had sex with a woman and she lied
so yeah yeah it was my choice to not use
a condom and ejaculate I could not use a
condom it wasn't his choice to get her
pregnant he ejaculated in her of course
he did it's his fault so it ends there
so all right so once he ejaculates in
her and he's and she's lied to him it's
still his fault he believed her true
actually true stranger
I get it he shouldn't have believed her
I'm assuming this is more cautious but
with the like I think the point we're
making is like you're promoting a double
standard because life's full of double
standards though
I'm just saying that I'm not trying to
I'm just basically saying every if I'm
having a son the conversation I'm having
with them it's one million percent your
fault but we're not talking about your
son like you keep bringing up your son
as many of you know who knows just
banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want
super thanks below every donation helps
and it helps make what we do possible